Henry I know moving to a new house can
be a little scary but you'll get used to
it
our son has taken to this doll in a way
that we find perhaps a bit odd but it
seems to be therapeutic
tap and check your phone
you miss me okay shopping you
want to play Let's Play
hold on hold on
hold on Rising
ly
you're not the producer from Deep line
where is my sister Chucky Tucker help
Caroline you don't have to do this I
miss new friends of the end knife drop
have you seen the news is that Chucky in
the white house we're responsible for
Chucky we're going to DC he knows where
my sister is we're gonna
ah
again
he's cute in the White House
[Applause]
[Music]
I think you found the Oval Office very
interesting
[Music]
what are you guys talking about killing
people what the
thank you
[Music]